pour les amateurs de natation ces
derniers mois le quotidien ressemble à
une brasse coulée ou le comble à une
traversée du désert mais à
joué-lès-tours depuis hier l'espoir
renaît la piscine bulle d'eau a rouvert
ses portes aux habitants qui en
profitent tant qu'il en est encore temps
le reportage d'aurélie renault première
longueur de crawl pour nadège nageuse
régulière elle était privée de sa
passion depuis des mois au commissarait
que je nage voit la même chose pour
jérôme qui rêvait de remettre un orteil
dans l'eau même si la reprise est un peu
compliquée sans prendre un coup dans le
bassin extérieur la jauge est limitée
six personnes par ligne d'eau sur des
créneaux de deux heures maximum
la réservation est obligatoire elle se
fait sur internet ou par téléphone à
partir du moment où on a communiqué pour
une ouverture qui a eu jeudi
les appels n'ont pas cessé sur le centre
aquatique beaucoup de visites aussi
d'abonnés mais aussi de gens
pas abonnée au centre aquatique mais
désireux de repartir et une activité
physique le bassin intérieur est
réservée aux sportifs de haut niveau et
aux détenteurs d'un certificat médical
bulle d'eau est le seul bassin ouvert
dans tout le département
les annonces du troisième confinement
n'ont pas de conséquence sur cette
ouverture
il n'y a eu aucune consigne demande donc
aux activités de fermer leur piscine
avec des bassins extérieurs donc nous
continuons d'accueillir du public
les adeptes de brasse ou de crolles sont
accueillis mais attention les créneaux
sont complets jusqu'au 11 avril